joining me here right now on the Rich
Eisen show is Michael Kay how are you
Michael great rich how you doing well
who is Erin judge
walk me through who this kid is Michael
you know what he's I guess a real corny
way to describe him as he is kind of a
gentle giant about as polite as you
could ever be a guy that after last year
I didn't think had a chance to do
anything close to this I mean he looked
lost at the plate strike out forty two
out of eighty four plate appearances and
he worked over the winter closed up
holes in the swing and now he's an MVP
candidate so I think it's a different
guy than the guy from last year he
really is well what about keeping his
head screwed on straight you know what
if anybody could do it you can never say
anything definitively until absolutely
I'd be surprised if this guy went off
the deep end
ye-yes great support system great
parents and I mean rich let's be honest
you're considered one of the nicest
people in the industry and compared to
Erin judge you know you're you know one
of those evil humans a ball foul nice
this guy is no kidding
I mean because I mean it's it's off the
charts the amount of attention that he's
getting right now and have has there
been anything that you've seen so far at
the plate where where the league has
tried to correct itself and he's already
beat them to that punch Michael well I
talked to John Smoltz the other day on
my show and he said that this guy
amazingly because of the size covers
every single part of the strike zone
every part he doesn't have a hole that
you can weaken in the strike zone
but the way Smoltz thinks you could get
them out is the high fastball above the
strike zone or the low fastball below
the low strike but smoke does a lot of
people can't really throw that and one
of the strengths that judges have this
year is that he's a he's very patient
and every time you look up he's 3 2 so
he'll take those pictures sometimes when
he chases he cheats his upstairs but
usually you get a big guy out by
throwing him outside but he hits home
amongst the right field now and I think
the biggest adjustment that he's made
rates last year I think he was 2 for 22
with too strong
hikes this year receiving over 290 with
two strikes that just doesn't happen
though he does he's able to discard the
last pitch if he didn't like it up and
swung throw it and you take it pitch the
pitch rather than gain the game or slump
to slump e he's made adjustments like
nobodies I've ever seen in 30 years
cover baseball Wow and we saw the the
funny bit he did on Fallon show where he
showed a picture of himself although he
was wearing like Clark Kent glasses to a
bunch of New Yorkers and asked them
about who this guy was I aren't judging
they had no idea it was errant judge
asking the questions are the Yankees
protecting him keeping him out of a
spotlight away from national
conversations on shows maybe like this
one Michael they're certainly you know
I've got a constant asking to get him on
my radio show and you know that
simulcast on the yes networks is kind of
family yes and they're just not you know
that they're holding them back and I
don't think he even wants to do stuff
like that he's very humble and every
time Meredith marakovits on the YES
Network interviews him on the field
after he does something extraordinary he
always brings the attention back to the
team he never wants to talk about
himself and it's almost like he took the
Jeter handbook and tightened it up a
little even made it better so it's just
amazing what he's doing where is he from
he's from California's from the Bay Area
went to Fresno State and his parents are
both teachers he was drafted by Oakland
out of high school and always wanted to
be a baseball player but his parents you
know said you decide he said no I want
your help and they said you know it
wouldn't be a bad thing if you got your
education so he went to Fresno State and
than the Yankees drafted away with the
pick they got because the Indian sign
Nick Swisher no kidding yeah that was
the compensation pick Michael K from the
YES Network and then his show the
Michael K show 3:00 to 7:00 p.m. Eastern
on the New York metropolitan area
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
all that said Michael when the Astros
came in and I mean they beat the Yankees
about the head neck chest in and head
area and then ruined Derek Jeter night
about three minutes flat Astros the best
team you've seen this year
at that point not now not without
Keuchel not without McCullers but their
lineup is really dangerous and the
Yankees will go into Euston on June 30th
July 1st and July 2nd so that should be
interesting but I think the Yankees
kryptonite is is obviously
Keuchel they can't beat them so the last
thing they want to do is see them in a
short series and you know they've never
been able to figure them out but you
know this the second time he's gone on
the DL with a neck injury and you know
the team is all the concerned but what I
what I've gotten out of the first two
months of the season rich and I know you
watch a lot of the games yes III just
thought the Red Sox coming into the
season we're heads and shoulders above
every team in the east they've got a lot
of holes they're very ordinary and they
really really do miss gave it Ortiz they
haven't replaced them I mean mr.
Moreland is batting cleanup that's just
not the right shot so I look at this
Yankee team and I thought that they
would compete in September being the
running for the second wild-card and now
I'm convinced and you know I'm not
easily won over and I'm not one of these
homer announcers and stuff like that I
just really believe they've got a chance
to win the American League East base
they really have a good team what how
did Jerry Mami's comments about Tanaka's
translator go down in the Yankee
clubhouse absolutely absolutely no
ripple effect at all it was just
shrugged off it didn't make much sense
when Jerry said it and I think what
happened and I'm not trying to get into
Jerry said if you listen to the whole
exchange he thought that there was
something wrong with Tanaka and the guy
that was accompanying Rothschild was the
trainer I think he was embarrassed he
forgot about the rule and then he just
saw that's a dumb thing to do Jerry's a
great guy obviously he's going through
more serious things than this right now
no Doug I just think if that was a
reacting to the fact that he thought it
was an injury first and then he realized
oh that's right he could have the
translator come out well in all
seriousness though is Tanaka hurt
because I mean ever since Derek Jeter
night he has been dreadful with the you
know with the exception of maybe his
last start Michael the last start and he
hit that 13 strikeout game against the
the A's but I say pump the brakes on
both of those starts because those are
not good offensive team so I backed
everybody and everybody says well he's
not hurt he's not hurt he's not hurt
well I could think he got a pitcher to
forget out a pitch in one year last year
he was sigh young word
that's how good he was he was 14 and 4
and this year he can't get anybody out
like people spitting on a splitter and
although the velocity is the same it
doesn't seem like he has much confidence
in throwing that fastball so you know a
lot of people think it could be
confidence wise maybe got confidence in
that game against the Angels and I bet
he has a real good game against the A's
on Sunday because that's a team that's
going to swing in this a lot and not
really be patient but m15 like the Red
Sox are really good hitting team the
Astros the way he's pitching now I don't
like his chances Michael K joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show putting your
allsports hat on other Jets tanking
Michael what do you think what's what's
going on how's that playing out in the
New York area with the Jets releasing
all their veterans like this well let's
put it this way either they're tanking
or they have the most in that front
office in the history of professional
sports so I think mike McKagan is pretty
smart and I think they're taking which I
don't get because I mean there's no
guarantees in the draft
we don't know Sam Donald's coming out
and if he does I mean is he going to be
great I'm going to USC quarterbacks have
been great so I mean are you tanking for
that one guy and and you know what else
does it make sense right you okay if
you're taking them why why are you
starting the count it makes sense to
start a nagging bird so you can blew
that second-round pick if not maybe he's
the answer maybe you don't have to tie
guy I don't understand anything what
they're doing I just thought well here's
what the Jets are gonna wind up doing
kick Michael you ready for this because
as you know I've been following this
since I was coming out of the womb
they're gonna start my count he's gonna
get hurt then they're gonna go to petty
he'll get hurt then we'll go to
Hackenberg who win enough games to
prevent them from tanking properly that
is exactly what's gonna happen
right there yeah you know what they want
done games at the end I mean in New York
Kristine has this habit
the Jets one ridiculous games at the end
that they shouldn't have the Knicks won
ridiculous games at the end that they
shouldn't have and you know they
completely sabotage their job pick so I
like to know what the jet plan is and
also how to Todd balls feel about this
you can lose 14 games and you're really
gonna keep you job I don't think so I
know that he wants tank no I agree with
you and before I let you go when you
bring up the Knicks you had a brilliant
interview I texted you at the time with
Dolan amidst the Oakley madness and I
this would I am NOT tongue-in-cheek I'm
asking in all seriousness is Dolan
latched to reality as an individual on
planet earth seriously I believe he is I
think he's a lot smarter than people
realize uh and I just think that there's
this I want to say this the right way
there almost seems to be a little bit of
arrogance about the Phil Jackson thing
where he's saying okay I was so bad
let's see how you like this because he
could have gotten out of the CLS of the
third year which was this past year and
he picked up the option which I thought
was sheer lunacy but I just don't think
he wants to be blamed for the next
problem so he went out and his payments
got 12 million dollars a year and he
thinks he should be better but I think
Phil is really disconnected from reality
way more than going
I mean Phil's building a team and
drafting players to play a triangle that
the day he's gone off the property
Madison Square Garden will be discarded
so you're getting players for two-year
experiment that nobody in the NBA agrees
is the right thing to do Michael
like I said love watching you as much as
I can and from what I've noticed best I
can tell you have for all the judge
homeruns you've been calling stuck to
your home run call of SIA and you have
not used a judge type pun once am i
correct Michael I did and one of the I
think maybe his eighth or ninth on run
which was a majestic shot I think I said
as he rounded third all rise but then I
started to think you know what you could
really get caught up in this nonsense
and and and really I mean where does it
end I mean in conversation I'll say you
know Lisa you know just a judge ISA
Supreme Court judge but the way I look
at it rich John sterling has that stuff
that's his copyright let him sign that
stuff on the balls I'll just say see it
and uh I now literally do so so thank
you for coming on Michael appreciate it
see ya thanks Michael KITT not yeah well
Mike okay
but Michael K you're on the Rajasa the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stay
since across the country and audience if
you liked that video be sure to download
our app don't have any memory on your
phone let's start to delete some of
those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about